we have such a fine show I just want you
before we get started check out this guy
in the front row sir stand up this is me
if I had testosterone so what's it like
your penis actually works how does that
do you imagine Andy if I was that guy I
don't want to you like me out of a
sexual no yeah I drop a good weekend you
have a good time a good weekend yeah I
did I had a nice weekend you know what
happened this weekend that I noticed 300
people announced they were running for
president just this weekend there are so
many people you know it's I mean it's
ridiculous every five minutes this
weekend someone else came out and said
I'm running as a Democrat for president
of the United States who here in this
audience is running for president I'm
just curious let's hear it I vote for
testosterone Kona
got my vote vote for testosterone Conan
he's Conan but manly I'd actually like
to hear his policy point we'll get to
that in right no it's like it's the
latest fad running for president mhm mhm
it's like it's it's like planking or you
know the tide pod challenge you know
what I mean yeah yeah everyone
everyone's on let's think you gotta do
it right my friend did it you got to do
it yeah there are more Democrats running
and there are Netflix specials right now
you know it's crazy there are people
running who I have I mean they're
obvious they're obvious people show
announcing that they're running right
and then there are people running not
you then there are people like the mayor
of South Bend Indiana announced he's
right the mayor of South Bend India and
he has an unpronounceable name yes so
that's always good yeah
he says he's running to get out of South
Bend Indiana
Howard Schultz Howard Schultz the former
CEO of Starbucks is talking about
running you seem thrilled yeah wait why
are people booing are you booing him or
are you booing Starbucks yeah anyway the
people are booing him and who already
have free Wi-Fi his policy is he wants
to build a wall around Dunkin Donuts
wouldn't matter it wouldn't matter
they'd go over it or under it you go to
Dunkin Donuts a lot you go through it